well it just fit in in this book the
theme that that david miller who collect
these are his favorites of my essays the
theme that he identified and used this
the title is a commitment to to politics
because it it it has often seemed to me
that there is a certain kind of of
political theory and perhaps a certain
kind of elitist politics sometimes on
the right and sometimes on the left of
people who don't like politics they
don't like the messiness they think that
there must be a true path and somebody
must know it and once we know it we
should just somehow find a way to walk
along that path and not be distracted by
personal ambition and political
interests and all of the arguments it
happened with John Rawls that certain
people read his book which was a
wonderful book and decided that he was
right and that the difference principle
was the crucial principle of decent or
egalitarian or just politics and that
therefore the Supreme Court should start
enforcing it and you didn't have to win
elections because we now knew we now
knew what was right and that that kind
of
of a lead ISM that kind of on the left
its Vanguard ISM i have i have always
disliked